the mass adoption of Bitcoin will only
happen when people feel that there's no
other option A lot of people for example
during 2021 when they saw what happened
during the world a lot of people just
flock to bitcoin because there was
really no other option and so I think
the same is going to be true again for
social media apps when people just get
censored people they lose their
livelihood because their business is
essentially shut down by these
corporations they will have to learn
they will have to learn how to use these
decentralized applications and so I
think adoption comes out of desperation
that's how I see the future going